Liberia caught between poverty and
progress in the interview Liberian
President Ellen Johnson Sirleaf your
excellency you are in Germany to receive
a prize for your efforts in rebuilding
Liberia you have been the president for
eight years now you've started numerous
initiatives to improve the education
sector to promote reconciliation to
promote economic growth you've come very
far but despite all your efforts
let birria still is a very poor a very
challenged country do you sometimes fall
into bed after a very long working day
as the president and wonder why am I
actually doing this to myself oh there
may be moments when when I wonder what
else could I do I never wonder why I
always wonder if I've not done enough if
we could all achieve at a much faster
pace so generally you know I'm very very
confident in the future and very
satisfied what we're doing even though
not at the pace I want to see what do
you think are your greatest achievements
so far as the president we've been able
to start the process of reconstruction
infrastructure building the
institution's getting the the laws and
the policies right settling our large
external debt to open up the fiscal
space getting kids back into school
health and educational systems and we've
had to tackle just about everything as a
priority ensuring that the environment
is one that promotes geoagro
democracy ensuring people have all the
freedoms starting all the reform process
restoring our international
relationships and so it's it's been a
challenging
situation but again as I said we're
pleased with the progress is there a
particular area where you are unhappy
with the progress that has been made so
far in our educational system because it
we have stated that it's our number one
priority the foundation upon which
everything has rests it's been difficult
because most of the professional
teachers had departed the country the
schools were broken down the everything
about it required reform and that has
contributed to the slow pace and to the
lag in our building the delay capacity
at the level that will ensure
satisfactory implementation of our
development plans when you came into
office you were greeted with a lot of
enthusiasm both locally and abroad and a
lot of people when you read the
commentaries in the media expected you
to kind of change the country overnight
to build a very stable prosperous
Liberia how do you cope with these kind
of enormous expectations that that
people have it's always difficult when
when people have been suppressed for a
long time and have not had opportunities
for a long time and all of a sudden
there's hope you know hope that comes
from from a new government and
enlightened government so managing those
expectations are very very challenging
endeavor but I must say that because
we've been able to make enough progress
to have given people hope and again have
given them a stake in society where they
to feel that the future belongs to them
because of that we've been able to have
10 consecutive years of peace and now we
think we can build upon that but still
there's no quick fix when a country has
been destroyed over two decades and all
institutions infrastructure systems have
been totally dysfunctional you can't fix
it in in 10 or 20 years even and how do
you cope with it personally
you just mentioned you understand the
needs of the people they are enormous
and Emily for instance if you travel the
country and people come they make
requests and you as the president of
course you know that you can't satisfy
all that demands immediately you know
that you first have to find the
necessary funds for instance how do you
cope with that personally well I guess
first you have to be truthful to the
people by letting them know there are
limitations in resources financial and
human in those cases where one can
respond to them in a small way one tries
to do that one has to also keep pointing
out that development is not just a a
government task or a leaders test if
element belongs to everybody and
everybody must make a contribution so
it's a continuous process of engaging
them and enlightening them and working
with them and you know despite the
challenges the message does get through
on the other hand you said it's
necessary to enlighten people of course
Liberia still faces challenges I mean
you've always spoken out very strongly
against corruption for instance do if
you read reports for instance by
Transparency International and there is
still a great deal of corruption does it
sometimes make you said that you are
trying to explain to people what is
necessary but you can still see that in
everyday life apparently for many people
it's still quite difficult to change
from the usual ways that's very true it
is one of the most challenging issues
that we have to face corruption became a
way of life as a means of survival and
so he became a part of the body culture
is systemic
it goes beyond government or any
individual group or person we've tried
to tackle it by putting in measures of
prevention and that means improving
people's compensation to reduce their
vulnerabilities coming up with the laws
and the policies rebuilding the
institutions rebuilding capacity we
still have some lags when it comes to
punishment because the system is still
part of an overall systemic
environment and so punishing people is
difficult in that situation we've been
changing laws and you know improving the
quality of our judges limiting bribery
and all of that and as a matter of fact
some progress has been made if you look
at the transparency international
indexes we've improved if you look at
the Millennium Challenge account indexes
we've also improved considerably but we
still have a long way to go how does it
make you feel if you have people like
for instance Lima and goo bovi who got
the Nobel Peace Prize together with you
who are now coming out to criticize you
does that hurt you because I mean you
know what you are doing it has to come
with leadership one has to be able to
take that as no escaping it I keep
saying that perhaps she's too young to
know the many struggles that we all went
through to bring the freedom that enable
her to be able to criticize and so that
that's part of what it what it takes to
be a leader and do you sometimes feel
that you have made any mistakes in
running the country oh yes I mean nobody
can say that you're perfect in in the
decisions you make so I've made some
mistakes maybe sometimes but not being
sufficiently hard on people who haven't
achieved the goals in a time I've wanted
what come from a small society where
everybody knows everybody and sometimes
that puts a lot of pressure on the
leader even if you want to be hard-nosed
and take those decisions so but but
generally you know accept the small
mistakes I think the bigger achievements
have certainly way outweighed the small
mistakes here and there
you earned a great deal of criticism
abroad but also locally for appointing
some of your family members to high
position of government now when you look
at it would you see that as a mistake no
in the realm of things many of them
earned a position before I became
president I saw no reason to remove them
if they were doing a good job the
capacity is limited in many
we're talking about at three
appointments sometimes we forget that
people who have the same name I have
rarely know relatives from some of them
have not even known all my life but in
those cases where they were to wreak
relative like sons and have served a
particular function I think they've
responded to specific needs that I had
and they can now move on as as one or
two of them are how satisfied are you
with the assistance from foreign donors
like Germany for instance in the
rebuilding of Liberia welfare police
with the response Germany has has worked
with us on our debt
Chancellor Merkel was particularly
instrumental in bringing the European
partners together the United States
remains our number one partner has
helped us to rebuild the army the
European Commission is a major partner
in infrastructure and that goes for our
multilateral partners like the World
Bank and the African Development Bank so
if there's anything that has slowed the
progress is our own capacity limitations
because we've not been able to negotiate
as as fast as we have wanted to or
implement at the aggressive pace that we
have wished for but we're quite pleased
with our partnership even our African
friends who have helped to keep the
peace what are the priorities for your
remaining years in office infrastructure
our power our ports our roads so that we
can develop the private sector which is
hurting our educational reform program
silver service reform we've been doing a
lot of work on that to make sure that we
get rid of the bloated public service
and we bring in the capacity
constitutional reform being able to to
do more on Liberian ization
diversification of the economy so that
we can move toward Agra processing and
industrialization and responding to the
big challenge of youth unemployment
giving our youth
skills and technical training so that
they too can take a much greater
participation in the economic life of
the country and continue to promote
democracy the freedoms that our people
enjoy which they have not had perhaps
all their lives today freedom of speech
Association religion we hope to continue
all of that and and build upon the
progress we've made consolidated and
make sure that I keep saying that our
2030 vision calls for being a
middle-income country by the year 2030
and it makes for years when I complete
my chairman our agenda for
transformation I hope will put it on an
irreversible course toward the
achievement of that long-term goal Madam
President thank you very much for the
interview thank you